the kids will have to make it on their
own some of the world's most
high-profile billionaires including mark
zuckerberg warren buffett and bill and
melinda gates saying their children
won't inherit their vast piles of wealth
instead they plan to donate their
fortunes to charity and want to teach
their kids the value of hard work and
it's not just the ultra rich some
celebrities wanting to do the same a
long time financial planner saying this
what i've seen from other parents is
that they don't want to provide too much
money that they take away their child's
sense of purpose if you leave hundreds
and millions of dollars to a child there
is a potential they won't have work
ethic and will sit around living off the
money that's not healthy most people
need to work to feel fulfillment in life
david i agree with the sentiment however
you know when i leave this earth the
person best position to decide which
charities my money should go to to me is
is my child who has my values that i've
instilled in them
this is by and large a conversation that
the elite of the elite have with one
another only three percent of americans
get more than a million dollars from
their parents most of us have to work
really hard
our entire lives to get what we achieve
in this life now joe biden and
aoc and
the squad may take care of that if they
continue to raise taxes as they seek to
do on
on americans they may wipe out a lot of
wealth you know all of all of that to
say the great irony here is for these
elites who are talking about giving
instead their money to charity and said
it to their kids they're ultimately
giving it to progressive groups that are
doing the very things that are going to
make it impossible for their kids to
have a good life which is a great irony
here instead of just giving it to their
kids and letting them prosper yeah
julian warren buffett though he does
make a good point in explaining his
rationale he said he wants to leave his
kids quote just enough so that they feel
they could do anything but not so much
that they feel like doing nothing
i think i could get on board with that
i'm like thinking about this and like
hypothetically if i was a billionaire
you know what would i do which is like
you know what would i do if i was like a
ferret but um
i think so i'd come where i'd come out
somewhere reasonable in the middle like
warren buffett um because
now having a daughter it's very hard to
think well i ha if i had this money
i could conceivably say to her you know
what i'm not going to make sure that you
and your children are okay for the rest
of your lives i'm going to give
everything to charity that seems
a little bit harsh um at the same time i
grew up in new york city i have seen the
perils firsthand of children that are
you know that are exposed to an over
abundance of privilege from day one it
usually backfires it usually hurts them
warren buffett is right about that tell
me a family that is happier because they
are wealthy you know show me a child
that grew up who didn't have to work and
decided not to work and is actually a
better happier adult as a result of it
i've not really seen that so i think
it's probably
you know
look if you're a billionaire and you're
in this position um it is a good problem
to have
um but i i don't envy them in that sense
yeah it's a good point kennedy will you
be giving your vast billions to your
children man i got to get the best
billions first and i'm really excited
about that like once i get the vast
billions i'm just going to sit around
and look at it for a while and then you
know i'll probably think about it i'll
probably say no
i'm keeping my vast billions and then
i'm giving my best billions to the
french bulldog rescue association of the
universe yeah but then at the last
minute i'm gonna i'm gonna cave and buy
them in each golden rocket ship um and
you know and hopefully from your lips to
god's ears
that happens i i do like the fact that
there is more investment in private
charity i think that's a much better
direction for human beings to go in than
a concentration of wealth in
centralized government so i i don't have
a problem with that and
with bill and melinda gates and their
divorce i bet bill gates was the one who
was like the kids are going to get
anybody i'll give each of them five
million dollars of math and now they're
split one is like oh yeah well guess
what you can have all your dad's
billions
so i think they're probably going to
amend that clause so i was actually
thinking about that in the in the midst
of the divorce you know bill gates worth
about 130 billion there was reporting
back in 2011 that he was going to give
his kids again it's just reporting who
knows 10 million dollars each that's
quite a sum i mean i think i could live
with that if my dad's like here's 10
million dollars totally i think i could
retire comfortably on that amount right
now uh i will say that to jillian's
point yeah to me you know fulfillment
and happiness comes from a sense of
purpose it comes from family values and
feeling connected with others and that's
true true and unrelated from wealth or
money and i think if i had vast billions
i would honor the fact that i'm living
in the society where education and
travel is possible so i think i would i
would want to i mean i'm saying this now
i could change my mind but i would want
to treat my children to the education
that they could have access to to travel
so that they see the realities of the
world and so that they are exposed to
other cultures and needs throughout the
world and that they could use their
education for good and i agree that a
little amount is healthy and definitely
too much as we've talked about before
can be cruel and i what is this saying
it takes a lifetime you know to create
wealth and a generation to destroy it so
absolutely i think the best thing you
can do is to instill in your children a
sense of responsibility and
responsibility itself and not just
numbers the millions and billions don't
matter at the end of the day it's all
about faith and family hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else